hey everybody and welcome back to let's
coaster I'm still not entirely used to
how the whole YouTube live streaming
works I'm just used to twitch and just
pressing the life button on OBS instead
of also having to do it on the dashboard
of YouTube so I don't know that's maybe
why it was quiet for a while sorry about
that
anyway welcome back to a cohort today is
going to be the last day that I'm
opening this park file probably ever
maybe we'll see who knows I just wanted
to do one last well I wanted to do one
last video or a live stream depending
what I felt like doing where I just
showed it off because I felt like there
was still a bunch of stuff that I wanted
to talk about and there was a bunch of
stuff that I did between episode 16 and
the final video which I didn't get to
show off because I thought it wouldn't
really work for an episode but it's
still stuff that I thought was worth
talking about
be it the fact that I went through the
whole coaster and added nighttime lights
everywhere I fixed up the layouts in
certain parts and I just generally
filled up some of the areas which were
empty and untamed even still during the
last episode I think it could also be
interesting to look at the coaster from
almost the sort of planets called planet
coaster college perspective because I
think it's an interesting courses to
look into there were a bunch of ideas
that I had regarding this coaster to
maybe make a planet Costa College video
out of primarily the idea of forced
perspective which i think is the most
important thing at least for me
personally
throughout this build so that's
something that I want to talk about as
well so maybe some tips and tricks along
the way we'll come back as well as I
know probably a healthy dose of
self-criticism as well we'll see about
that
move this out of the way so yeah here's
Jaeger horn I'm actually gonna unpassed
the video because it was pause the whole
time now I will need to say I'm sorry
about the terrible frame rates that this
livestream is probably going to have
which isn't going to be entirely down to
OBS it's really just going to be down to
the game because this park file is
extremely laggy at least on my computer
I don't really have the best computer
and there's so much in this park file so
even though a cheat engine and time
lapsed footage might make it look like
it's doing all right
it really isn't this thing is melting my
computer and as you can see that the
framerate is not that great but I'm
afraid I can't really do much about that
there are also just certain limits to
the game I suppose and it's not even
that bad you know now that the camera is
standing still but as soon as I start
moving in camera and right the coaster I
think it's gonna be really annoying so
yeah that's something to keep in mind
I suppose so here's llego horn the full
map as you can also see yourself if you
download it on the workshop you know
what I should actually do I should go
ahead and just turn off all of the
effects of wait I already did okay I
thought I had a healthy dose of ivory
shade at this point but apparently I
didn't hmm okay I'm just gonna leave
that on a little bit of ambient
occlusion
I really can't fix up the framerate much
more maybe this tanks it a little bit
but it's not like there's a lot of
reciate actually on it right now so yeah
I don't think I'll need to do a few V
because there's a pretty good POV in the
video already first I kind of want to go
over some of the things which I ended up
doing after episode 16 so for once I
actually placed lights alongside the
entire rail and some of these are just
really simple like some really small
lanterns around here on the fence I
think I even put down yeah like one
extra light over here this whole lift
hill over here has a bunch of extra
lights basically I just wanted to make
sure that almost along the end
layouts that would be lights especially
among the most interesting that's like
the fence here and some of the the
outermost curves and I should probably
switch to nighttime mode to show that
off a little bit because I didn't really
get the show off the nighttime look of
this coaster too much in the cinematic
video but I definitely tried to make it
work at night as well so there are some
very basic lighting I have to say it's
not that great it's really really basic
but most of the the trek at least the
most interesting bits are lit up and all
of the buildings have at least some form
of spotlights going on as well oh yeah
and also I should say if you have any
questions or anything that you want me
to show off just drop it in the chat and
I'll look at it so for this question I'm
living in Brussels at the moment but I'm
from the Netherlands I get this is
sometime is a bit of a source of
confusion but yeah that's that's
basically where we're at now right now
so yeah I actually really like this
coaster a lot more with the lights I
don't know why it took me so long to
finally add lights to some sections
there were always some lights but they
were mostly just decorative I didn't
really think about nighttime before so I
went back a few weeks ago and just added
all of these lights which I think helps
out a ton in making this coaster look a
bit better and especially some scenes I
think worked really well at night and
I'm kind of wondering why I didn't
include them during the cinematic video
like this area here because it looks
pretty cool I think and the same goes
for the buildings I guess even at night
especially this station building I think
looks kind of cool one thing that I
always try to keep in mind when I'm
doing lighting and trust me I kind of
did a very poor and rushed lighting job
on a lot of this but something that I
always like to keep in mind is to show
off the lights as much as possible well
not really as much as possible but at
least make sure that every light is
physically there and visible but at the
same time a little bit hidden so there's
a spotlight here for instance
shining through the fence which is the
light for this station a lot of a lot of
people I think will sink their lights
into the ground or into scenery pieces
to make them invisible but I think just
for realism purposes it would make a bit
more sense to have it light up from just
across the path or something like that
how many hours that this take you
honestly I have no idea
the video is themselves I think if you
add up all of the time lapses together
it's somewhere between 60 and 80 hours
but then there's a lot of me also just
going around the park outside of the
episodes trying to fiddle with things
slightly moving stuff like I spent a lot
of time just grabbing single trees and
moving them around until I was happy
with the exact placement of the trees
like I know I was really trying to
tinker with the placement of this tree
because I didn't wanted to break any
sight lines but at the same time I
wanted to have a tree there so things
like that I think ended up taking a lot
of time which you don't really end up
seeing in the videos also trying to
tinker with what the layout should be I
think was the most difficult bits what I
ended up doing was painting a general
layout of the park on the ground with
ground textures so I actually painted
the layout of the coaster on the ground
with just textures before I actually put
the real coaster track in but I think
things like that mostly ended up taking
a lot of time so I don't really have a
good estimate but I definitely spent
over a hundred hours on this which to be
honest spread out over two years really
shows that I was working on this every
now and then like I definitely wasn't
continually working on this it was just
an hour or a few every now and then I
didn't end up putting any lights on the
roof actually because I didn't really
find a good way to put lights there
maybe it would look a bit better but I
think it looks all right with no lights
on the roof I did put on lights are
actually a bunch of lights on the clock
towers so there is a bit of attention
that but the roof is entirely dark my
favorite build in planet coaster in
total I would honestly probably say
Jaeger horn that's just and I find it
really difficult I think my favorite
build in planet coaster is llego horn
it's the build that when I look at it I
find the least amount of things that I
feel like don't work even though it's
not the most over-the-top coaster it's
the one where I put the most amount of
thoughts into everything I think and
it's the one where I'm generally the
most happy with it but my favorite video
of planets goes in my channel I think is
still planet coaster the planet coaster
which is really weird to talk about but
the one where I just basically built a
small planet and had a coaster go around
it it's just something about the
simplicity of that thing because I only
built it in two days but still it works
out really well I think and just makes
for this really kind of unique coaster
that also only works in video like it
looks terrible in-game but I felt the
video for that did turn out really cool
so I don't know despite the fact that I
basically put in zero time into it and I
made it in two days I think that's my
favorite video but my favorite overall
project to look around in is probably
Jaeger horn also I just noticed this is
this incomplete oh no no way no I did
have that right I just wonder if I was
forgetting some supports here I
remembered putting some supports
underneath that Costa Trek I just
couldn't see it but yeah that's there
all right so that's good actually
underneath this bridge there is pretty
much no scenery so that's something to
try and not pay any attention to
although I also kind of feel like that's
realistic because as a guest you will
barely really see that space it's really
just a bit of rock work underneath the
bridge are you going to make another
coaster and if so what kind of coastal
would be well I have to say I don't know
if I'm gonna
start another coaster planet coaster in
the foreseeable future
I'm still pretty busy with park attacks
and planets ooh
especially planet 2 coming out soon I
want to keep some time free for and I
also want to get back into city skylines
and I don't think I can juggle all of
that and working on a coaster and planet
coaster but I do want to finish the ski
resorts and there will probably be some
more episodes of stala fire as well even
though Rudy and I have both been kind of
procrastinating on it and Oprah is the
only one at this point who is actually
trying to get us it's actually be
productive but something of that wall
will definitely come as well what's the
feeling of building another coaster from
zero happy said or bored I feel like the
start of building something new is
actually the most fun because then you
can really still experiment with things
and for me personally it's also the most
yeah it's also the most interesting
because you're completely free to do
whatever you feel like and it doesn't
you don't feel too much of a burden to
bills to I don't know make something
nice because for Yaga horn I find it
more and more difficult to add stuff to
it because I put so much thought into
the first things that I built that
everything that I added to it I was
really trying to you know make sure that
it fit in and that it didn't ruin what
was already there and especially as we
became more and more complete you really
just try and complete the puzzle and for
me at least it becomes harder and harder
to make things fit in whereas if you're
starting something new you could just
kind of do whatever you feel like doing
do I still like playing part X oh yeah I
love it I definitely want to finish the
campaign it just takes a lot of time how
did you get the timing for the coaster
so the timing is actually something
really interesting to talk about I think
I'm gonna go back to daytime at this
point because we've seen coaster enough
at night I think
but yeah the timing I think was really
interesting because the Taiping is
actually slightly off which oh wow it is
actually completely off if you look at
that there but yeah that the thing I
think
is every three trains there will be two
trains that synchronize and one train
that doesn't and this should have just
been the one train that didn't sink I'm
just gonna skip ahead and see if we can
find the next two trains on the drop but
yeah I couldn't get it to synchronize
perfectly and this is also something
that you see in the POV because on the
first drop in the POV video it doesn't
sync with the other train and then on
the second drop it does ok the sync is
actually completely off nevermind I
think that just kind of got offsets
after a long time of running this park
but yeah another way I basically just
did it is I kept changing the the
minimum waiting time and it just took a
lot of time on error until it
synchronized a few times I was actually
able to set it up so that it
synchronizes every single time which is
you can see it's completely off now
because either this one's first or that
one's first but I was able to get it
right but then I would have to run four
trains and the issue with that is that
there would always be a train waiting on
this part of the break run and then
usually also train on this part of the
break run which was terrible and I'd
rather I don't know sacrifice a little
bit of synchronization to make the
trains actually continuously run and
never force people to wait at any point
in the track why don't you add a
chairlift I just felt like I couldn't
really fit in one without ruining what's
already there here I guess yeah I really
couldn't find a place to fit in a
chairlift I guess we could maybe have
one go above this section but then at
that point you're just kind of going
over everything not really interacting
with it in a meaningful way so no I
didn't end up anyone I think if I wanted
to add one I would have tried to include
that in the general plan for the layouts
from the get-go what are you most
looking forward to in planets ooh
basically the interaction of the animals
with the scenery I think this is
something that I've already said quite a
few times so I'll keep it brief but I
really love the fact that animals
interact with everything you build it
just made
everything feel that much more real and
that much more solid so that's really my
favorite thing about the game I knew
pretty much that they were going to get
the models of the animals right
frontiers is really good at that and
they're just good at making games for
your or look good in general I think I
was just not sure if it was going to
work out as well from a gameplay
perspective but with how the animals
seem to interact with the scenery that's
I think perfectly fine
multiple thefts have occurred there are
no security guards whatever I'm not too
concerned about that how much time do
you think you've spent on this coaster
in total not entirely sure but
definitely somewhere upwards of a
hundred hours but you know it's spread
out over two and a half years almost so
it's really kind of kind of on and off
how many pieces are there in this park I
actually don't know I tried to measure
that recently by just multi selecting
the entire park and my game crashed and
I'm really afraid to do that again
especially on stream so I'm sorry I'm
not gonna try to measure it but I think
it's not too terrible the real the
biggest problems with piece counts are
just the buildings with custom roofs
like this station building if I try to
click on this you could see my game is
freezing for a bit yeah that's nearly
15,000 pieces the church is definitely
less bad but also oh this thing is blue
principal did I upload this on the
workshop I should probably try it I know
this thing is blue principal because I
put it on the workshop yeah 3,000 so
yeah it's not even that bad and it's a
pretty small park but there are a lot of
very small pieces everywhere when I make
a POV of the carousel no sorry but I
will finish the ski resorts yeah I'm
gonna see when I get some time to work
on that again because I haven't in a
while but I definitely want to finish it
some tips for a beginner in planet
coaster I definitely want to get to some
tips especially you related to this
coaster but my general tip that I like
to give people is to look for
inspiration in real-life theme parks I
know a lot of theme parks
are available on Google Maps in 3d and
you've got street view images Google
images can also help or the roller
coaster database RCD be calm but yeah
just look at stuff is usually what I do
and sometimes you just get inspired by
something something sometimes you really
like a certain picture or a certain part
of a park and I don't know that can be a
really good starting points you could
even try to recreate something which you
know isn't quite as creatively
interesting but I think making
recreations is a good way to get to
learn how parks and rollercoasters are
put together in real life but also in
planet coaster because it can be a way
to try and force yourself to use the
pieces in a creative way and you know
get to you get to know the game a bit
more so yeah that's something that I
think is a good way to get started
oh hi Joshua hope are I finished
supporting gambits and theming this
station Plaza area and you can build a
surrounding area like a mountain lodge
area sounds good honestly yeah now
something that I also thought would be
cool to talk about is forced perspective
I was considering making a planet
coaster College video about this but
it's a really hard kind of topic to do a
tutorial video about just because it's
not really something you build or do
it's something to try and keep in mind
while you come up with whatever it is
that you're coming up with and I used
some forced perspective ideas in a bunch
of things in this park I think the most
interesting and most notable use of
force perspective is in the church on
top of the hill I try to make this hill
look as large as possible while in
reality the hill is actually kind of
tiny and I think the church plays a
pretty important role in that especially
from this front perspective or this
perspective especially which I think
works out really well as you can
probably tell because I made this
perspective
a picture and many thumbnails but yeah
the church is actually really small and
it's built on a much smaller scale than
the actual in-game grid even though it
looks like it this building is
absolutely tiny and I also try to make
use of some of the smaller pieces in the
game so while the tower for instance
might look like it's made out of a
complete you know 4 meter by 4 meter
wall sets if I get some footballs and
this is gonna take a while because the
game is lagging but yeah if I get a full
wall as you can see it's actually much
bigger than the tower is so if it were
to be made out of actual wall sets it
would be this large so this really kind
of shows you just how tiny the church
tower is one interesting way also to
illustrate that a bit is if you just
copy over this entire building and put
it next to the station building and
there go out my game is protesting at me
doing this so I'm just gonna pause it
for a second but yeah if you put it down
next to here you can see that the tower
of the church is actually tiny it's
really small but just the fact that
guests can't really come close to it I
think hides the fact that the church is
really small and really not built to
actual human scale and this is a trick
that's stolen straight out of Disney
Parks a lot of Disney parks will do this
mostly the castles are very famous for
having tiny upper floors or sometimes
when they do put a building on Brook
work they also just make it a really
small miniature so yeah there's that
what video card do I have the gtx 970
which is not really handling this park
too well I'm afraid
so I don't know if you want to run this
park with with the better fps definitely
get a better video card but this is all
I could afford when I bought it but yeah
it's also something to keep in mind that
you know just the church being small
doesn't really make the force
perspective work by itself something
that I tried doing to make this work a
bit better is try and keep the guests
far away from the church and it's also
just in the general landscaping so
this case for instance I wanted to make
this hill look as large as possible so I
have this valley just in front of the
hill between the part and the hill so it
seems like the hill rises a little bit
more just because you have this little
valley down here and it just doesn't you
know it start up start going up
instantly and just the overall layering
I think works in that regard as well you
might be able to notice that I keep my
trees on top of the hill really small
they're all kind of sunken into the
ground whereas if you go down here you
definitely see some larger trees there
are just some four trees here and there
so just the fact that everything kind of
progressively gets smaller as you get up
the hill is part of what makes the
church illusion work a bit better I
think as well so yeah this is also why I
struggled to come up with an idea of how
to make it planet goes to college video
about it forced perspective isn't really
something that you can you know you can
build or instantly put into place it
just it relates to pretty much
everything which makes it hard to to use
you kind of have to plan it beforehand
in this case also I think just the fact
that you have the curve of the track in
the foreground and then the the church
in the background I think just the
overall composition of this with these
sort of like diagonal lines in this
direction looks kind of cool like this
definitely the general shot that I'm
most happy with but the fact that you
have this foreground here makes the
church seem a bit more believably
human-sized as well oh wow somebody just
loaded up the save and apparently has 60
FPS so yeah my computer is just terrible
I'm at what game got you hooked on this
genre it's hard to say I guess it could
be a rollercoaster tycoon when I was
younger but it also definitely could be
rollercoaster tycoon 3 the thing that
really got me into creatively building
stuff was raw goes to Tycoon 3 with the
custom scenery community I just watched
a lot of videos on YouTube when I was
younger of moonkin for the win or strat
alas
Murph the engineer all of those people
were uploaded roller coasters back in
2007 eight nine and that basically
inspired me to get into the game that's
what that's how I got into the custom
scenery community of roller coaster k3
and then once planet coaster came out I
just sort of naturally rolled into this
community as well with I got a say the
big you know advantage of having that
roller coaster tycoon 3 community
knowledge knowledge and experience in my
back pockets because I have to be honest
like everything I do I owe a lot of it
up to the roller coaster kin 3 community
in which back in the day was really
centered around forums and lots of
people gave me so much feedback and tips
that really helped me become better at
that game which I think helped a lot in
my planet goes to stuff as well I don't
think I would be where I am right now
without the amazing roller coaster q3
community which for a large part is
still on planet coasters well like the
whole pronation is basically all shy
guys world forums of the roller coaster
kin 3 community also now there are some
other interesting bits of forced
perspective on this which are a bit more
obvious I think this building has
progressively lower floors in fact the
bottom floor is way too large it's like
it's four meters yeah it's just a full
wall so it's actually ridiculously big
kind of out of scale then the middle
floor here is much more of a realistic
skill I think if I show it like this you
can probably tell that it's actually a
lot smaller maybe I should just get a
full wall piece just to be able to tell
just how it's all the different floors
are this is a four meter wall yeah this
is about four meters this one's a little
bit shorter and then once you get up to
the top floor if I raise this to the
same height it just starts sticking out
like crazy like the top floor of this
building is tiny although I think you
can still probably fit a human in there
just because the roof is pitched but
yeah that's just a general way of making
this building seem like a three-story
building even though in reality it's
more like a two-and-a-half storey
building
just basic Disney main street's
kind of forced perspective I think oh
and yeah SimCity 3000 is also awesome
that definitely was one of my favorite
creative games back in the day as well
also if we go to the back here there's
something that I never really showed off
before but I finished the queue of the
flat ride it's really not that great we
just have this weird little pavilion
here at the back I got the pavilion in
the back and yeah it's really not that
nice I try to experimenting a lot with
different buildings to fit in here but
nothing really worked it was all bit
over the top I didn't want to have a
full complete building but I also wanted
to have something which made this
entrance stick out a bit more now that I
think about it I probably should have
put a sign here because this is a bit
too anonymous oh well that's basically
how I ended up finishing this part of
the quake All Right see you later
Jonathan what game is more attractive in
building for you planet coaster City
skylines planets you or others it's
really hard to compare I think I like
planet coaster and well planets due to
similar decree I think most because you
just get so much freedom in terms of
what things look like like every little
piece every shingle of this roof was
basically placed by me like everything
is customizable so you have a lot of
control over how things look you have
that less so with city skylines but I
think that's also fair it's on a much
larger scale like on city skylines you
can actually build things on a large
scale whereas with this I spent two
years just on this little park so that's
completely different I think also City
skylines for me is not just interesting
from an aesthetics point of view which
planet coaster and planets ooh or I
guess but I'm also just really
interested in urbanism urban mobility
sustainability these kinds of things in
general and real life so City skylines
is kind of a playground for me as well
to just play with these general urban
issues in kind of a digital god mode
sandbox we don't have to worry about
politics or social issues that
your life cities come with now back to
the topic of force perspective for just
a second
I think the quote-unquote Main Street
vehicle horn has the same idea of many
Disney Main streets you can tell that
the second floors are actually really
small this one is a tiny second floor
which a person would definitely not be
able to fit on this one has a much
larger second floor actually or first
floor
how do it's not like a british-american
thing I always forgets but anyway this
floor this floor right here the middle
one is much larger than this one but I
also wanted to have this one this
building be much bigger in general
because this is kind of the the center
points of the the general streets and
then this building again has a tiny
floor here which is really small but
just kind of helps to sell it as a
two-story building
I also just generally looked for some
variety in these buildings in general
these buildings are totally all over the
place by the way
this one's completely different style
they're all kind of a bit of
experimentation so it's a bit of a messy
street it's not my favorite part of
Jaeger horn but at least it was fun to
experiment with these different styles I
think and I think also this building
here with the chief beef is just very
kind of standard Tyrolean or Swiss
affair just with a bit more detail on it
I think in city skylines you have a city
with 50,000 people and 30 transport
lines hmm I have actually no idea what's
wrong with that I have to also admit my
City skylines in-game knowledge is not
like great so there's a bunch of books
that I honestly don't know about I've
never heard about that issue before how
do you decide what is going to go where
in your park and what scenery you are
going to build my biggest problem is
that I have ideas but constraints later
into the game this is definitely
something I struggle with a lot as well
and for some reason I always return to
paper and try to sketch things but even
when I try to sketch things down I
really can't get it right so honestly I
just tinker about in the game
just generally building stuff with no
detail whatsoever just trying to figure
out a composition and layout and until
I'm and when I'm happy with it I just
start building it so for the station for
instance for Jaeger horn I know I spent
a lot of time trying to figure out how I
wanted to do this I didn't just
instantly start building this and start
detailing it I at first just started
experimenting with wall pieces and roof
pieces in the game just randomly putting
them in different shapes and positions
trying to figure out how I wanted it to
look like then eventually I came up with
a sort of composition it took a picture
of that and then use that as a guideline
to know what I wanted to do when I was
building there the full building so
that's how I approached that and then
for the park as a whole I just used
terrain textures to try and mark where I
wanted certain things to go like the
coaster track buildings things like that
and then try to visualize a bit what it
would look like just to have an overall
idea and try help put my thoughts into
something real so maybe this is a bit
different for everybody as well but this
is how it works for me
in English the first floor is the ground
floor I think there might be some
differences yeah yeah it's like a
british-american difference I think
either way as long as we all just kind
of try to maybe emphasize a bit what we
mean exactly it should be all fine ski
resort is definitely still happening I
want to finish it I've just been too
busy with some other stuff recently but
I do want to finish the ski resort so I
guess that also answers the question of
whether I want to do more Planko in the
coming weeks I've got another standalone
video coming up as well besides the ski
resort which is a really strange video
that I don't want to spoil anything
about because I think it'll be the best
video if I just drop that randomly with
no context whatsoever but I will drop a
random standalone planet coaster project
sometime soon as well foliage that's a
good point actually
give us a ride I'll do the POV soon
although I have to say not too sure if
it's going to look very good in this
frame rate but yeah also finally one
interesting notes this building is very
crappy I know I actually redid this
building because I lost progress on it
and I couldn't care about it when I
redid it and I even forgot to give this
dormitory
so this dormer is very facade II which I
guess for a theme park sort of works but
in the original version that was
actually a roof connecting this dormer
to the actual roof of the building but
nowadays ya know this is just a 2d
cutout of a doorman that's that's
something that I definitely kind of
regrets about this although in the end
we do have a proper backstage setting
for these buildings which even though
it's not that great and it doesn't
matter that much I do like having that
in the back just to be able to pretend
like this is a real park and there could
be no some sort of backstage setup
behind all of this
also yeah this was an attempt to put in
some of the different architectural
styles that you find throughout the Alps
so this is a baroque building that
you'll very commonly find in mountain
towns in the city centers around the
squares they often have painted
decorations on the building so I try to
recreate that a little bit with some of
these Christmas decorations this
building is a very typical farmhouse
style except with a lot of extra
decoration on it this is a timber work
building that you'll also find more in
urban centers and then this is actually
all just one big interconnected Swiss
looking facade which was mainly inspired
by the Swiss section in Europa Park so
that's that and then of course there's
the Biergarten here as well which I
didn't really even show off in the final
video I thought it's not that nice but I
wanted to have it from a realistic
standpoint in this park because you need
some area to sit down and have food and
things like that
and even if this beer garden itself is
not the best I think if my game is not
going to freeze there we go
you do have a really cool view of the
park and the coaster from here
read this loud no well I'm sorry about
that in America the floor that has the
main entrance is the first floor if
there's a floor underneath that it's
grant level ah that's interesting
all right so hmm I guess I can I'm just
gonna use first floor for ground floor
then and second floor for this touch is
weird as well because like the word for
dipping which is the Dutch word for
floor it feels like literally translates
to something like the deepening like it
sounds like you're going down but in
reality it goes up and like the first
floor is the trade of leaping I think
actually I'm not even sure anymore
forget about it there's another
interesting example of forced
perspective that I still wanted to show
off before I moved on and it's super
accidental but I think it works out
really well and it's this bridge here
and if you stand over here on the path
it's a very obvious sight line
I think the sight lines are along with
forced perspective and well probably in
combination some of the most important
things in Jaeger horn I spent a lot of
time just walking on the paths trying to
figure out where things should be placed
and this is like one of those obvious
sight lines and this bridge works out
really well because it looks like the
station is kind of far away you've got
the bridge here and you've got four
arches leading to the station but in
reality the bridge is on an incline so
if you're looking from the part you
can't really tell that the bridge is on
an incline or on an incline but in
reality it just kind of looks like the
station is further away than it actually
is
so this was honestly entirely accidental
but I think it works out really well as
a sort of forced perspective and when
you're on the coaster I think the
coaster is going way too fast to notice
that the bridge is kind of clunky
especially because you're going over
this airtime Hill also you're really too
busy to pay attention to the fact that
this bridge is weird so yeah I think
this is honestly probably my favorite
example force perspective I I'm not sure
if any theme parks have done this in
your life with the bridge now trying to
change the size of the bridge as you go
further away to make the bridge seem
larger than it actually is but it works
out really well in this case I think so
yeah I'm happy with that but I can't
take any credit for it that was just a
lucky stroke of genius I guess but yeah
those are really the main interesting
bits of force perspective I think the
most interesting sight lines and the
most important sight lines are well for
one this one looking out from the path
over the coaster definitely this one as
well this is a very wide section of path
here where I tried to make the coaster
look as good as possible from this
perspective and then a bunch of further
perspectives as well I tried to keep
some clearings in between the trees to
make sure that from here you can see the
station and the the Tower of the church
and the same goes for here if you just
kind of get it right you can see all of
the buildings are lining up so if you're
walking here in fact if this were a
section of a real-life park then you'd
be coming in here and well either you're
on this path and this would be your
opening to the coaster or your what is
what is this camera doing here or you're
coming down from this path in which case
you know you can see all of the
buildings just in the background like
this which I think works really well so
the placement of the trees and
everything is just kind of meticulously
done to make sure that everything is
revealed when you walk into the area
that this would be in and I guess the
same goes for this this other path where
you can enter the section of the park
from because then you have the church
right in front of you and just around
the corner the station roof speaking in
here which partly disappears because the
shingle pieces disappear really quickly
which is kind of an issue if i zoom out
you can see the single pieces
disappearing I put a bunch of red plank
pieces underneath the roof just to make
sure that the roof doesn't completely
disappear but yeah don't zoom out too
much or the roof disappears it's a
little bit annoying
also did I accidentally remove a piece
of the roof here I did this used to be
here what did I do oh oh that's not
great oh well forget about it I don't
know if that occurred in the final video
as well I didn't notice it at least
maybe that's just something I messed up
on this save something I messed up on
this save as well as this little post is
here it's a bit of a mistake that's a
post that I used I think to make the
roof symmetrical but I don't know why
they wouldn't post is still here it
didn't pop up in the cinematic video at
least I removed it there but apparently
I didn't remember to save that save file
what is your favorite type of coaster
and planet coaster hmm that's really
difficult I'm actually check the menu
for a second I can't create a park
building with just the standard pieces
and no DLC if you're interested in that
kind of stuff I can actually recommend
Rudy's planets raw series where he tried
to see how the raw version of planet
coaster fares nowadays but personally
I'm not too interested in that no I
don't think I'll be trying that anytime
soon although I can definitely see why
it would be a good exercise because this
game has gotten really expensive with
all of the extra DLC and things so yeah
also I sorry I didn't say hi yet but I
come under reward the coaster named
after me yeah that would be a good
choice I guess for my favorite coaster
it is definitely one of my favorite
courses in real life but I think my
favorite coaster is gonna have to be the
topper track RMC I think that's just the
coaster that they the mate the best
although I would put the hybrids cars on
it but just when it comes down to the
track design and everything and the fact
that it's in the game at all
I'm really happy they and at the top for
track coaster in the game I also think
that the the mech launched coaster is
pretty great even though I never
actually built anything with it and yeah
the looping shadow coaster is actually
really nice they did a good job on that
as well the Anubis
what is the Anubis again there's a
graveyard in one of the career parks
that has your name on a grave I think
that should be the Western Park rights
with the lake in the middle with a giant
roller coaster with a big Tower in the
middle of the the island in the lake I
think that's the park either way it's
it's a park that was made by a bunch of
community community managers so aside
for me I can remember that Rudy also
worked on it as well as @fo I hope I
didn't forget anybody else it's been a
long time but yeah a bunch of people
from the community worked on the
different sections of that career map
and they ended up adding our names to
the graves which is a bit I don't know a
bit of a bad omen I suppose but also
really cool I tend to forget about that
because I don't think I ever made a
video about that map but yeah I made the
coaster and the building on the island
in the middle of the lake in the middle
of the map so that's why my name is on
one of the graves hmm oh it's the Joe
vanilla hyper fair enough
well it's well made I gotta give it that
but that'll never be my favorite coaster
on basis that to open all the Hyper's
are a bit lame although I also think
that they are over hated they're not as
bad as people say they are I think I
think Goliath is pretty fun it doesn't
have too much airtime but some really
good positive cheese and it's not a
rough or anything so it's pretty
enjoyable Pixar please I have to be
honest I don't really like doing
recreations so I think I'll pass that on
to other people maybe oh brother is
gonna do it one day
which has been your most favorite
project to build and planet coaster hmm
that's difficult for one I think it's
not actually gonna be--yeah horn because
it's been so challenging to try and
build this thing
hmm I think that's probably also planet
coaster as in planet coaster planet
coaster it was really fun to try and
experiments with how to make that thing
look like it's on a real planet and the
whole time I was basically thinking to
myself and just wait until people see
this thing I was just looking forward to
drop that thing the moment I came up
with the idea I was just pretty much
happy with it so yeah I think that was
my most enjoyable cause it to build I
can you build a gun alone this live
stream I have to say I am NOT going to
build anything on this live stream I
just wanna showcase Jaeger horn so I'll
stick to that I had some notes here
about something I also wanted to do and
talk about it just give me a second oh
yeah right I still need to do a POV and
maybe some foliage notes and other notes
some detailing this coaster or stuff
that haven't shown off speaking of which
oh yeah yeah I know I'm just here to
flex you're right now I was thinking
that I could make a real time showcase
video but you know for one that has more
efforts than doing a live stream so you
know screw that but also I figured might
as well make a live stream out of it so
people can ask questions and other stuff
and I can actually respond to comments
because theirs will be the last time
that I'm showing this and I don't know
this is the project that I'm probably
most proud of in the game so I just want
to spend as much time trying to talk
about this thing as I can until it
becomes really obnoxious I guess is what
I'm trying to say what was I doing
oh yeah right I did change the track a
little bit I know I actually complained
about the track having way too many
lateral G's in the final episode and I
did find out also that the majority of
the track is actually
fine it was mostly this curve and the
other curve going around the transfer
tract which was bad so how I ended up
settling this oh god my game is really
struggling trying to render this I ended
up settling this was just twisting the
track a bit and then putting these extra
supports in place there are some lights
on this as well to support that track so
it doesn't look terrible
but it does look a bit wonky and also I
have to say this is why the catwalk is
so far removed from the track for this
section because I honestly couldn't
bother to redo the catwalk because that
was definitely one of the most annoying
thing about this whole project just the
fact that the catwalk is made out of
hundreds and hundreds of upside-down
fountains is kind of a chore to do that
so I kept the the catwalk the same I
mean do you even call it a catwalk at
this point it's really just some
concrete next to the track but yeah I
did the same on this side just rotate at
the banking a little bit more and then
put some wooden stuff underneath it to
support it which is also weird because
now you have a double layer of wooden
planks but I think it works alright and
especially on the POV you don't notice
it too much I'm not sure how long this
live stream is going to last for just
until I run out of things to talk about
or until you guys run out of things to
ask questions about I suppose if you
were ever going to expand this park
which you aren't what type of expansion
would you make
well the idea behind Jaeger horn has
always been that it's one themed land
inside a park with a lot of different
themed lands it could be probably a
Disney style park because it is very
heavily themed and expensive but maybe
even something like Fantasia land or so
if they had more space to actually build
things so if I were to expand this I
would really just make Jaeger horn one
section of the park and move on to a
different themed land be it something
Asian or a different European country or
something completely different like
African or
American which are things that I haven't
done much at all
should probably do more but yeah that
would probably be what I would do with
this if it weren't for the fact that I
want to end it here well for one because
it's in this corner of the map if this
were really a part of a larger park it
would definitely be over here somewhere
but also as you can see the frame rate
is absolutely terrible even when a game
is paused and I had to build like this
so one of the most annoying things also
when you're building a park is that
longer you're building the more laggy
the game gets and you sort of gotten
used to it I don't think you need a
really great framerate in games like
this but at the same time when you start
a new park and it's 60fps again it's
just so refreshing to finally not have
to deal with the lag anymore so yeah but
yeah if I were to make expansions I
would make different themed areas each
with their own headliner attraction and
make it know based on a different region
in the world probably around Diego horn
different European countries and then
other sections of the park would be
different continents something like
Eurasia Gardens maybe or fantasy Valley
would you make a small village in planet
coaster if you had the time or half the
time I don't think so but I would love
to try building a city and planet
coaster I did one in roller coaster can
3 which don't look it up it's really bad
but I really like the idea of building a
city in this game because you can
absolutely control everything from the
look of the streetlights on the street
to the foliage of the balconies in the
buildings which gives you so much more
my new detail control than city skylines
does but at the same time it would be
really hard to pull off how is the speed
on their coaster always decent if I make
a mine train it is always very slow I'm
not sure I think I meddled with the
friction it's not it's 0.9 or so I think
no ok ok the friction multiplier is
actually untouched interesting I thought
I moved that to like 0.9 maybe that is
why the synchronization is off hold on
let me
experiment with something here yeah this
save for some reason it didn't save my
synchronization like the minimum waiting
time and things like that I know I did
miniature minimum at the party arrival
whatever whatever the case for some
reason synchronization in this save is
messed up so it's not synchronized as it
is in the video but I think I had
friction multiplier 0.9 could be one as
well but even on one it runs fine but I
have to say mine strains just run out of
their kinetic energy not that quickly
but they definitely do pretty quickly so
even though you can't really tell too
much because none of the track is really
close to each other you lose a lot of
Heights between the top of this lift
hill and then the bottom of this lift
hill so in this case the lift was really
tall and then the next tallest point of
the whole layout is this bridge which as
you can see is already much lower and
then from there going forward the
tallest point is this hill which is
quite a bit lower than this hill which
is quite a bit lower like you can really
tell that the layout is getting lower
and lower very quickly and by the time
that you almost wind up back at the
second lift Hill I also had to take this
valley because you really have to go
below normal ground level because
otherwise the Train would be way too
slow so yeah the way I avoided losing
speed was just keeping it close to the
ground and having it continuously going
to lower and lower until you hit the
next liftoff oh hi ladies Einar yeah it
is very weird to see a blue menu again
it's also a bit annoying to see this
game again because planets who keeps
making me realize just how bad planet
Costa looks in comparison
no because planet coaster looks
necessarily terrible but planet zoo just
looks way too good we do stand Silver
City in this house yes also hi operator
what are my hopes for Max and Moritz in
the efteling since its theme is going to
be similar to yours I think it's gonna
be beautiful I've really high hopes for
the theming but I have to be honest I'm
I'm still disappointed that they are
removing Bob for it
understand it but Max and Morris is
definitely not going to be as fun as as
fun of a coaster for me but I understand
it because Bob isn't supported by the
manufacturer anymore and they did need
that you know bridging coaster for kids
because at the moment they don't really
have a good kiddie coaster so I think it
totally makes sense it looks great I
think they're gonna pull it off really
well but I will forever be salty about
Bob disappearing well I built a gondola
and planet goes through well I suppose I
didn't ask you though it
yeah the lighting and planet Zeus is so
much nicer and also you can see the
anti-aliasing
in this game is bit iffy it's really
harsh and it just makes the already
harsh lighting stick out even more and
planets who has really great lighting
and anti-aliasing so just all together
look so much more easy on the eyes okay
make it night again because I want to
see the lights alright
sure thing sorry that I'm keeping my
game paused quite a bit here by the way
I'm just a bit concerned about the frame
rates when it son paused also this is an
interesting perspective I think also
kind of on purpose because you've got
like some benches inside this building
here but I don't think I ever really
showed it off in the final video but
yeah
hi SPR hold on let me see those who
still have the awkward paths where you
can't really make a super straight path
or like a square you can easily do that
by selecting angle snap I have to be
honest I'm not a fan of the path system
and I've probably voiced that quite a
few times but if you push it hard enough
you can do most of the things that you
eventually want to do even if it's a bit
of a long way to get there and making
straight paths and squares is absolutely
fine unless you're getting into very
organic
squares with smooth layouts that kind of
flow into cars it's kind of difficult to
achieve that but even then I think
eventually you can push the system to do
that like the path work over here where
a lot of these planters in the middle
are really just ways to try and cover
the gaps left behind by the path system
which doesn't matter too much because I
really like having these planters in the
middle of these part areas is this the
end of planet coaster if planet zoo is
released I mean I don't want to make any
promises about that but I think in the
foreseeable future I'm probably going to
play planet Zoo instead of planet goes
to but at the end of the day I am a
massive theme park enthusiast so I will
definitely keep traveling around to try
and write rollercoasters and visit theme
parks and it's still my main interest so
I'm probably going to come back to
planet coaster for at least something
eventually
but yeah the parking is very wonky I
have to agree it's interesting actually
because I found in the last couple of
days a lot of people have gone back to
my planet Costa College video about
pathing which I suppose are a lot of
people playing planet Zoo and trying to
figure out how to make this part system
work which yeah I was that was one of my
major disappointments about planet Zoo
as well because I think the pass system
really kind of deserved a rework as well
from what I've heard from frontier is
that it's difficult to make it work
better because of the terrain being the
voxel terrain which fair enough
I know I said at some points that I
would love to see the Jurassic world
evolution paths in Planet soo but if the
reason that the paths don't work as well
as Jurassic world evolution is to have
the voxel terrain then I do think having
voxel terrain is a worthwhile sacrifice
it would just be nice if we could have
both the Jurassic world evolution path
style and voxel terrain what coasters
are highest on your bucket list
oof that's really difficult because
there are some courses that would be
really high on my bucket list but kind
of orange because they're just too far
away and I don't see myself going there
in a foreseeable future like well steal
vengeance fury three to five or
Intimidator things like that but I think
at least within Europe going back to
energy LAN dia is on my agenda for
Zandra partly but also for the bakoma
is it a firestorm which they're building
their new generations bakoma which
they're building anyway but that aside I
think most of the newest interesting
coasters in Europe I've kind of done at
this point I still want to go down to
parts of them to read to write Shambhala
that's definitely something I need to do
but yeah aside from that I don't really
have too many bucket list coasters I
have it on my bucket list to go back to
Japan and go to Nagashima spa lane
because I got a ride Haku gay and I just
want to go to and I guess you miss Paula
and in general and back to Japan in
general and yeah what else I don't know
I don't really have too much of a bucket
list honestly do you follow any other
planets youtubers and if so who do you
follow well generally the people that I
hang around with so the ladies I know
Rudy ring Camille ice PR etc free the
bear the Shan mcbird all of those people
and as for people that I just kind of
follow I mean from a sort of one way
perspective it's just me following them
could be anyone in the community kind of
I try to just keep my eyes open for what
is being released and not really
necessarily follow people so I just kind
of check out the discord groups the
subreddits YouTube to see what people
are putting out so yeah anything
honestly that comes out and grabs my
attention I'll check out we should make
a group trip to Port Aventura right one
day oh that's a really good idea yeah
do you know any good youtubers who will
stick to planet coaster instead of
switching to building zoos um I don't
know actually I think a large part of
the planet Coast community even though
they even the the theme park hardcore
enthusiasts have been switching to plan
ensue just even to build stuff with the
same engine but with better graphics and
weather if I could say anything I did
see that there was some person who built
a roller coaster in Planet zubeida I
don't even know which pieces they used
for it but somebody did that probably
they're gonna actually no they're not
gonna keep playing planet planet coaster
because they already did planets ooh
yeah no I wouldn't know who's gonna
stick with planet coaster yeah somebody
actually did that that's madness
I'm not sure if we can even still look
it up and probably we're gonna lose all
of the planet to beta blueprints but
yeah I did think it was a little bit sad
to build a coaster in Planet soo
although it is funny when I you know I
always try to look up what most people
look up about planets ooh and if you
type in planet Zoo on YouTube and type
the letter C I think one of the first
recommendations you get is coaster for
some reason a lot of people look for
rollercoasters in Planet Zoo which is
interesting and honestly I think it
makes sense that frontier didn't want to
include roller coasters in Planet 2 as
much as I am a fan of zoos that also
combine theme parks I think it would
just kind of distracts from the over
idea of a zoo and from the main message
of the game so honestly I think fair
enough although still deep down I would
love to build a combination of a zoo in
a theme park as well you know bring it
back to those roller coaster tycoon 3
days oh I really good luck recording the
thing style games keeps playing planet
coaster fair enough
if you're Dutch you can follow diving
style games for planet coaster videos
he's making some good content but that's
really just for the Dutch language
speakers
I think I am praying for planet coaster
- and if planet Costa - ever does come
out I'm going to be so hyped for it that
would really be my dream game and I
think it might happen I don't know we'll
see is there anything else I need to
show off here in the meantime a night
POV let me actually fix that real quick
somebody asked for it so that'll be a
good thing to play in the background
while I talk about stuff oh hi Mike
somebody was just asking whether anybody
is gonna keep playing planet coaster
instead of switching to planet Zoo but I
guess you guys are going to do a bro zoo
thing so but I was just talking about
how it's interesting that a lot of
people from the planet coast community
even though it's so the theme park
focused have switched to planet zoo and
kind of became hooked on it but yeah
you're right SPO they are completely
different gameplay ideas
would you like to have animals in plank
oh sure thing I mean what if okay that
is that was the most coaster but what if
ever
but what if at the end of the whole
planets line Frontier released like a
plan is everything you know it's a game
where you can do everything forget about
it this is not happening
but it would be cool you know at the end
of the day when they've built all of
these different games and they know how
to take all these different parts of it
they just release a game with theme park
elements and zoo elements and water
parks all in one that would be the dream
come true that would be something that I
would give a lot of money to make happen
it's not gonna happen but you know I
don't know wishful thinking I'm not
entirely sure where the whole planets
series is supposed to go and I know
there's a lot of speculation about
planet water park of Planet City or
planet whatever it is but yeah even
though I understand why they keep
everything very separated I would love
to see another game that combines these
different aspects like roller coasters
that going through rollercoaster going
through it was such an insanely flexible
game and you had all these different
communities within it as well it had the
zoo elements roller coasters water parks
firework simulation which was
surprisingly amazing like that game was
insane planets minecraft planet skylines
yeah that would be cool I'm personally
really hoping for a planet water park I
know it's not quite as popular maybe as
the other ideas but why is this train
not starting okay I'm getting out I've
been having this game and unpause mode
for a while oh oh it's closed no
interesting herp a derp
okay now we should get started let's go
oh hi Jason yeah I know rollercoaster
country soaked in wild exist but you
know that game doesn't look as good as
the plan of games planets will her house
I mean don't know if I see that one
happening but I would also love to see a
planet ski at some points I think that
would be feasible yeah we don't have the
synchronization because it's on testing
mode so the timing actually doesn't work
speaking of which if I'm done with this
POV I should definitely turn it on again
I mean open it again and see if I can
get the synchronization to work off yeah
that the FPS is really off it's really
terrible I'm sorry about that but yeah
this is what the coaster looks like at
night this turn is very over-banked but
I feel like it's over banked in that
typical for coma mine train kind of
fashion I think everybody who's been on
Colorado Adventure knows what I'm
talking about
that thing sometimes slams you into the
person next to you which I think it's
all part of the bakoma my train
experience so fair enough I'll leave
that over-banked turn in there I'll do a
daytime POV after this
Thank You Oliver did the budget not
cover lights for the tunnel yeah I guess
so I should have definitely put a light
in there I'm gonna be completely honest
and say that I think I just forgot about
that a lot of this lighting placement is
religious down to what the coaster looks
like off ride this is actually my first
time ever seen the coaster at night as
in a non ride POV at night
yeah it's clearly not made not made for
this there are some dark parts here in
there then again you don't want
everything to be lit up with lighting
but I'll be the first to admit that the
lighting y'all and this is a bit
mediocre except I think for the
buildings and the guest areas and some
quote unquote weenies
it would be cool if planets who
eventually got some expansion for more
fantastical animals like zoo tycoon did
I'm not sure if they're actually gonna
do that though because it seems like the
planet series is really focused on
realism and yeah I guess that speaks for
itself with planet Costa for instance
they really go out of their way to try
and make rollercoasters realistic I know
us roller coaster enthusiasts have had
some issues with this because it's not
always a hundred percent but honestly if
you look at it you know from a general
audience perspective it is unparalleled
just how realistic planet coaster is
from a theme park management perspective
if you don't count things like no limits
which are honest to god simulations so I
think they did a good job on that anyway
but yeah the the planet series seems
really focused on realism so I don't
think they're gonna add non-existing
animals although it would be cool to see
extinct animals yeah like maybe more
recently extinct animals like I don't
know Tasmanian Tigers or Dodos things
like that realization yeah sure
realistic is is that an e ology
neologism forget about it
daytime POV time and before I do that
let's open the ride and see if the
timing is a little bit less off now
didn't I just change the p.m. thank you
yeah would not surprise me if the
developer said that they're not earning
extinct animals because I suppose that's
not really their thing judging by how
they've been handling the game so far I
really like this perspective as well Oh
too many trees in here there we go
that's what I was looking for this is
actually a swamp tree but no I like this
thing so what in your zoo had you most
excited to build upon what will your
unique niche be well I guess within the
larger planets zoo community I can
honestly only set myself apart with I
mean what do I set myself apart with the
only unique niche that I have is that
have a lot a large following honestly
but aside from that just my general
interest in architecture and different
cultures I think will be at least for me
my biggest niche just going out of my
way to try and make exhibits as
culturally authentic as possible I think
will be really interesting kind of like
the Bhutanese Tiger exhibit or the
Taiwanese exhibit forget about the
Grizzlies for some reason that's the
most popular video on YouTube but it
sucks I mean you make a Japanese garden
yeah yeah that's maybe I'll build a
Japanese garden as well I I have an
inkling of a feeling that there might be
some Asian scenery in the game so there
are dodo statues and planets ooh oh
that's cool actually
also I should upgrade my PC sometime
soon because I'm getting well worse
performance on many of my builds than
many of my followers apparently so
that's something to fix
yeah I think aquatic exhibits are
definitely going to be a must but I
think that's one of the things which
they've kept from the main game to make
it a DLC you later on alright SPR enjoy
your late Spanish dinner well it's
quarter past 9:00 it's not even too late
for Spanish standards I guess I can i
watch the stream if you're not live
anymore yep I'll be keeping this on my
channel mmm anything I still wanted to
talk about get my notes again and yeah
I'm keeping physical notes of this
because I don't know why but having a
pen in my hand and physically writing
stuff down just it's still the most
satisfying and no sorry I won't be
building a gondola here I'm not going to
respond to that question about collabs
or we're uh we're thinking about it
perhaps we might maybe
wait I just responded to the question
well there goes that promise
how about blending your park with the
skybox the landscape background okay we
got the same answer from lady all right
nice hmm
we're too much we're too much on one
line here that's dangerous but yeah I
know there's not much that you can blend
into that skybox background in fact I'm
not really a huge fan of it although
sometimes I think it works well like in
some shots these mountains really do fit
the theme of Jaeger horn like this for
instance just having those mountains in
the back does help but yeah I didn't
really think about that too much I like
to think of my builds as just little
enclosed areas and if I would have no
actually cared to put in the effort I
would have probably put in some fake
clouds on the screenshots or videos
I don't remember Jase to but I do
remember seeing you here on YouTube with
the name Sam who plays games do you have
time for a collab on the level of KB
yeah that is that is a big question
especially because I'm very busy with
Park texts I know it doesn't seem like
it but Park text has been demanding a
lot of my time and those scenario videos
take a lot of time to make so yeah
that's something and also I want to get
back into city skylines as well at the
same time and I have to say I'm actually
really happy with the fact that Park
text has been very well received because
I was very afraid that people would be
kind of disappointed by the fact that
I'd be playing a much less known game I
suppose and let alone actually watch it
but people have been really excited
about him have been asking me a lot to
make more product videos so honestly I'm
really happy about that but yeah I do
want to keep that up
let me read through a bit more comments
here as a trick to making you build
underwater
I actually remember that pixilated who's
absolutely amazing at making dark rides
in this game they're so cool
but he found out a way to make that work
because in his dream machine coaster
well it's hard to call it a coaster it's
more like an experience it's it's not
even much of a dark ride it just kind of
makes really cool cinematic experiences
in the game using coasters but yeah in
his dream machine video there's a moment
where you're in this completely black
space and there's water below you and
above you apparently you can just kind
of stack water in this game I've
actually never tried this lemme try this
real quick but yeah he also apparently
just found a way to add a roller coaster
track in there so that worked so water
here and here oh yeah there you go nice
that's that's so weird
Wow that's very trippy alright nice so
yeah water is really just a single
translucent texture and it doesn't even
affect the texture underneath it which I
will say is a little bit disappointing I
still think that water in roller coaster
tycoon 3 looks a bit better than this
one
but then on planets who the water is
much better than in planet coaster Wow
Mike you're really asking Jason a lot of
questions here what are my thoughts on
Leo clan
I mean sure he's not the most patrician
music out there but it it's good for
what it is I am NOT gonna hate him
they'll clean it just for making the
lowest common denominator music because
I think he is good at it and let's be
honest
drunken looks is genius but yeah I kind
of relating to that discussion I do find
it interesting to the discussion that
Mike and Jason are having in the
comments at the moment I do find it
interesting that a lot of people who
view me don't seem to have planet
coaster or have it but don't really play
it and something that I've always sort
of struggled with is you know why people
would even watch my videos because all
that my videos really are is kind of
flexing I know that bear was joking
about this earlier but there really
isn't much of a point to it otherwise
just kind of I'm doing what most people
do in planet coaster I just show it off
but aside from that I don't think
youtubers are necessarily interesting in
any way so yeah now I've always kind of
struggled with the idea of why people
watch my stuff apparently a lot of
people just find it really relaxing to
see things getting built and I think
this is also just my final answer to
this question and something that I
relate to it well it's just satisfying
to watch a video where something gets
done where there's an end result at the
end there's just the creative process
going on I think this is why cooking
videos are so addicting even if you
can't eat it yourself it's really just
cool to see all of the raw ingredients
being used to turn it into something
else
just the whole like create
process is interesting to see it happen
and I guess it's kind of therapeutic you
know it's not like people are watching
my video is for comedic value or
education although I guess maybe to a
certain extent you could for at least
some of my videos where I talk with a
little bit of knowledge about something
even though most of it is just very
amateurish but yeah I've always been
interested in that and to be honest I
can relate to it at least in a sense
that I grew up fascinated by
rollercoaster tycoon 3 videos I would
always watch all of these videos on
YouTube where people were showcasing
rollercoasters so I totally get you know
that people feel this way I just always
wonder what is it that makes people
click on these videos that makes people
watch these things makes people come
back for it because I know it's not as
clear cuts what people watch it for as
opposed to comedy or entertainment or
education inspiration oh yeah that can
definitely also be a thing that's fair
I know a lot of people build stuff
inspired by my stuff I definitely notice
it every now and then on the Steam
Workshop or in YouTube
so yeah fair enough that's a good point
oh and yes ok so you can actually see
now that I changed the friction and I
reset the coaster the civilization is
working again so for some reason that
was an issue in the friction setting and
it didn't save properly I guess although
that is that is slightly off maybe I
should reset it to one let me see now
maybe I should I've switched it or
whatever the case it's not always easy
to get the simulation right why is it
why is it closed
what oh it's just because I changed the
friction okay of course
would you ever stream park sites like a
sandbox I have to be honest I don't
really like streaming while I'm building
stuff because I'm really bad at
streaming and building at the same time
it just kind of outs me for not being as
good a player and these games as I like
to be in videos because in videos I can
cut in time lapses I can cut out the
stuff where I suck at things or I can
cut out the parts where I build
something that doesn't look good
so at plus I can speed up the process in
general because I'm a really slow
builder so these videos are really an
idealized reflection of what my general
process playing these games is like so
no I don't think it translates to well
to streaming because it just I'm just
not good at it and I don't think I'm
good enough at the game to do it
besides these games don't really work
well as streaming games in general I
think and well I say this is a person
having watched a lot of streams of these
kinds of games but it's such a slow
thing that live streams of these games
that really amount to much and you have
to watch your whole life streams
actually see something being done as
opposed to a live stream where somebody
plays a platformer or an online game
where there's always something going on
so honestly I have to say I don't think
I'll ever do it but I would like to try
doing a sandbox park when I'm done with
the campaigns but also I have to admit
I'll probably be done with the
campaign's in Pocket X in the year 3000
it's gonna take quite a while
adventured oh my musket on squared
rollercoaster 3 was amazing yeah
mousqueton however you pronounce his
name was really great personally I
actually like watching Let's Plays of
games that I know I won't buy but I
enjoy Let's Plays of narrative games
like The Last of Us just to enjoy the
narrative of the game without having to
deal with gameplay because I'm really
really bad at video games like give me
any shooter and I will definitely lose
to everything so for me they are a way
of experiencing the cinematic aspect of
games that I'm not really good enough to
play and I like watching horror games as
well because I love horror games but I'm
also a total wuss so I like to watch
people play horror games I yeah I was
watching PewDiePie right away like when
he started becoming big and amnesia I
was all over that but nowadays I like
John Wolfe for instance who plays a lot
of indie horror games yeah I had to mute
ball cut here
do it before planning to do a planet
coaster is really too early to answer
that question I think
yeah I'm meteors crazy God I've only
played a couple of hurricanes and I'm
actually I don't know I'm not the worst
at it but I'm definitely not as
comfortable as it like to be so I just
prefer watching other people play
through them not sure what I think is
the scariest game
yeah I haven't even played that many
horror games I probably should at least
a bit more
I know I've actually played PT and that
was I was an experienced I could I could
not get far in that like I nope out of
that game after a few jump scares it's a
shame that Silent Hill never actually
came to be
I know it's bomb yeah I'm sorry you're a
bit late indeed I'm thinking about
closing the stream some time so if
there's anything you still want me to
show off in Jaeger horn drop it now
because probably not gonna come back to
this thing anytime soon
some other interesting bits that I
actually haven't really shown off much
or talked about is the souvenir building
here which i think is interesting
because it looks like a tiny building
but supposedly it's actually quite a
large building at the back of it the
entrance which sucks and is actually way
too hidden but at least it has one of
these Tyrolean bell towers which I
thought I made one in planet coaster
then I forgot where I put it and then I
remembered that it was in Jaeger horn
makes the entrance here and these little
roof covers which are totally not based
on the ones of symbolic in the afternoon
oh lady don't worry about being a
moderator in this Jen I just kind of
moderated you I just kind of made you
moderator because I was like yeah sure
yeah I'm sorry maverick you're a bit
late to the party I just kind of want to
show off some stuff that I haven't
really had the opportunity to talk about
in videos as well just to get that over
with the lookout tower is interesting I
guess this is one of my least inspired
bills and Plymouth ghosts like this is
the kind of thing that I build when I'm
not really into the game but has to put
out something like I hadn't played the
game for a few months when I built this
and I was just like ah bugger it I just
built something it's not great not
terrible it works out in the context of
the bike but it's definitely one of the
lamest things but at least it gives you
something to look at something like a
visual anchor point in this corner of
the park this bridge by the way I have
to say they didn't show it off as much
in the video but this bridge took hours
to build just this whole annoying
curving thing with this we're trying to
curve along with the track and I had to
like trying to make it seamless I am
never doing anything like this again god
that was the worst let's pitch this
coaster to GCI I would pitch it to the
coma if I had to pitch it to somebody
but yeah I'm happy with the bridge in
the end it does look pretty cool and
just this pond is really important to me
because it's just such a major sight
line as well as is I guess we should
actually walk through some guest areas
because I haven't really had any
walkthroughs through the park which I
know that the bro coaster guys like do
this for some reason I don't do this
nearly enough I do this when I play the
game but I don't do it on the videos but
yeah we got we got a queue here not too
interesting there's not even anybody in
the queue and then you just kind of go
up a hill here very laggy sorry about
that
and then the queue line here here's when
the queue line starts getting
interesting and think I've got this
bridge here with an overview of a sick
airtime Hill that does not belong on a
mind training like you get eat it out of
your seat on this one there you go
it's actually not that extreme but for
for a my train it is you're definitely
gonna get
quite a whip there in the backseat so
talking horror game to next to you miss
Resident Evil definitely not definitely
not also you have a really interesting
view of the the lift holes here because
even though the coast is testing right
now so you can't see being synchronized
actually should open it they should be
able to sing a nice here and then when
you're standing here you just get that
view in the distance I like this view
and the the final bit of curve going
around the cue this little cover here
and then there's a bunch of detailing
here which you don't even much notice
unless you actually walk here I had to
try and put in some very obvious fences
here to get people to walk around these
wooden posts because otherwise they clip
through it and actually as far as I
remember it kind of works and I made an
interior for the station as well which I
also didn't film anything but yeah this
is this is new it's not really great
it's very basic and I really had to
stick to the walls because the entire
building is as large as the station
platform in planet coaster so I didn't
have much space to work with but there's
very very basic interior parts here I
had to make the ceiling very low because
as you know the roof is entirely made
out of custom pieces I don't know if I
can get on the roof oh my okay
forget about that but yeah the entire
roof is custom made so on the inside
it's a it's a big old mess so I just had
to cover all of that up wait can I cross
the coaster track okay I'll cross here
thanks and then we step back outside and
you have this view which I think also
looks pretty cool and then this little
exit path and then you wind up back
outside
I love her texts to all the Dutch
players make their wooden buildings I
don't know if that's anything to do with
Dutch sness but perhaps I don't know I
did enjoy working with textures a lot
for this bill just trying to open all of
the wooden pieces and planet coaster and
see which textures I like most and the
station building is probably my favorite
building I've ever built in the game
trying to get a bit of a bit of you here
a bit of a better of you here God but
yeah I'm really happy with this building
it feels like the balance is just right
there's some funky spire things all over
the building which is a bit over the top
but it was generally inspired by the
sort of efteling style mixed with Swiss
Chalet style and then sort of similar I
guess there's the transfer track
building over there in the distance
which doesn't make much sense as a
transfer track building because it
doesn't actually have an employee path
going there so the employees have to
walk over the coaster track to actually
get there not great but I liked the
building too much to try and actually
add a realistic employee section to it
so yeah you can you can see that I went
for design over function here the
modernists are gonna be very angry at
this one but yeah sorry I'm a radical
traditionalist can't change it what does
the name llego horn come from and what
does it mean well in in the more of
Jaeger horn Jaeger horn is actually the
name of this whole themed area and the
coaster specifically is called the
Jaeger horn mountains rain because I
noticed that a lot of mine trains by
Disney have really long and four bows
names especially the big grizzly runaway
mountain carts minecarts big grizzly
runaway mountain minecarts yeah that's
it
so yeah the coaster itself is a long run
for Bo's name of jäger horn mountain
train which is based on the Jaeger horn
which is the
the name of this hypothetical mountain
here which just mean which means the the
hunters peak generally translated Jaeger
is German for hunter and horn is a
German word for a peak of a mountain is
it synchronized now I know it's highly
sure oh well we could see in a bit I
think also the the flat ride is a bit
under appreciated by me at least because
I didn't really show it off in the final
video but I'm really happy with this
flat ride skin as well the detailing on
it is honestly pretty simple and
straightforward but I think it works out
well with the Aspire that is made out of
jungle adventure pieces so I didn't even
have to put so much time and effort into
that one
any technique
the mechanic looks sad oh oh I don't
know I can imagine that some of my stuff
would be very sad here okay yeah no fair
enough this building has a lot of pieces
but in terms of like overall layout and
setup it's quite simple although I do
like the way that it works together with
this is the exit path wait to stand up a
pillar in the middle of it Wow
okay you guys didn't see that I never
messed up on that pillar placements but
yeah I just like this overall
perspective from here as well I just
always try to make things based on
certain perspectives especially of
course where you would be walking as a
guest in the park like they say the same
goes for this space over here
everything's just kind of set up to give
an overall overview of this section of
the park and I think this Swiss Chalet
style building works quite well from
this perspective as well so I'm pretty
happy with that the only thing that
isn't quite as nice I think is this
weird Pavillion for the cue of the the
flat ride speaking of which the flat
ride just has a very detailed and
over-the-top cue for just a simple flat
ride because you have this cattle pen
here then a whole garden walkthrough
with flowers and stuff and a bridge over
a pond which is a bit over the top for a
simple flat ride not gonna lie
this should be a cart at the exit with
free Jagermeister I love yoga my sir God
and yeah this is just a general Lukie
building a building to look at stuff
from which people don't do because there
is nothing to do here so the guests in
the game don't go here but personally I
thought of this space as you know the
kind of place we can sit down have a
sandwich or you know either
something you bought in the park or
something you bring with you when you're
a cheapskate like me and have a few of
the coaster because not enough parks do
this enough there's sometimes really a
lack of bench space in theme parks I
don't think there's such a thing as too
many benches so although you do gonna
make some nice you do have to make some
nice for the places for it like here is
well for instance I think you can sit
down and have a look at the coaster have
a go around and do stuff
okay built buildings as detailed as
plank oh yes definitely although yeah
pretty much I don't think anything will
hold you back in planets ooh compared to
planet coaster sorry I was just looking
at this and I'm like why did I not have
a section from this perspective in the
video this looks cool hmm alright well
that is the Main Street and there's a
very wide path this part is very wide
because it's generally the entrance path
where you would go into this themed area
from and again trying to kind of make
sense of where sight line should be and
what you can view the park from people
sitting down spent money that is fair
but neither do people riding roller
coasters
I feel like the pieces are more
consistent in zoo compared to coasters
since we sue they have years of knowing
how players build yeah that's that's
also fair I think in Planet goes to you
could notice that pieces were getting
better and more detailed and to some
degree also more flexible as the game
develops like the pieces in alpha were
really limited and we really can have to
push them in strange directions to make
them work for different themes they
definitely got better at that throughout
the years I think what are the picnic
umbrellas from let me check that out
wait where oh those are in front of the
building aren't it oh yeah
they are picnic umbrella one somewhere
in scenery I think setting seats in at
Neyland well there you go
yeah these are no wait this this is a
different umbrella but you get the
picture there are wait which one brother
is that hmm oh this is the one all right
yeah just a little bit of decoration in
front of the chief beep building this is
still my favorite perspective of the
whole build we are not going to do that
some angles of this Park for your very
piratey are you serious
[Music]
I wanted to give a shout-out to my self
host because he said Amsterdam teen in a
tweet announcing one of his life's live
streams and I felt like that was a nicer
way to say CSD so we need a koala zoo
Park in the future
duly noted
yeah I put some cheesy music in this
playlist but I think it fits the theme
of the coaster what else I think I've
given a pretty decent picture of the
park by now
now I've I've been spending almost two
hours just showing stuff and talking
about stuff that is way more than I
expected beforehand anyway so yep I'm
gonna get out of touch it again that was
pretty much the entire Park I think yep
yeah it is really small at the end of
the day so I'm gonna resume and go back
to my original location I'll end the
stream here but yeah I enjoyed having a
look at Jaeger horn I promised a day on
right so I actually do that while I end
the stream that sounds like a good idea
let's unpause it here
it reminds you of Matterhorn and I think
that was definitely at least part of the
experience I think a lot of the mind
train courses in general were probably
inspired by what Matterhorn did I did
always refused to make a pirate-themed
anything for vara was definitely not
steam pirates although I guess it could
be it's like a Flying Fortress and
airships are kind of piratey at least if
Treasure Island is to be believed
but yeah actually somebody asks a bit
earlier in the livestream what my
inspiration for this was and I forgot to
answer that question but just in general
it's the Disney mind train coasters
Seven Dwarves
Big Thunder Mountain big grizzly runaway
mine trains mine cards damn it I still
messed it up those are all just really
amazing coasters some of my favorite
themed coasters out there and they were
generally just the inspiration for this
this coaster interestingly enough if you
look at all of those coasters they do
obviously look very different from this
and in terms of how I built the terrain
and everything around the coaster
I was actually mostly inspired by model
train trikes like I really loved the
aesthetic of miniature train models just
the way that the rockwork and the
foliage etcetera was built around it so
that was actually my main inspiration
for how I themed this coaster I ended up
just looking at many pictures of model
trains and saving that oh and a giant
inspiration folder and that's where a
lot of the inspiration for this coaster
came from yeah sorry about the low FPS
if you want to have a decent
actual POV definitely check out the
cinematic video this coaster is
definitely more intense than the Disney
in mind trains you're right I personally
really like a slightly intense my train
I'm a really big fan of Colorado
adventure at phantasialand
which has some airtime if you sit in the
back so I did make this coaster to be a
bit more intense especially the second
half like this over here this here was a
ton of airtime there's some sustained
airtime twisted airtime a night on that
hill so yeah it's quite intense for a
mind-training coaster but I think it's
not too intense
Colorado Adventure hurts yeah yeah it
definitely does I won't deny that but I
love it no we are not putting shin guard
restraints on this I absolutely hate
them yeah
fun fact actually Colorado Adventure is
the only mine train that I have been on
because I've actually never been to
Disneyland Paris at least I went there
once when I was four
so I wasn't old enough to ride any of
the actual things so and yeah the Disney
park that I have been to which is in
Tokyo doesn't have a mine train I guess
I could have been to Disneyland in Tokyo
but I was so interested in Disney see
that I just ended up going there again
instead of visit to the other Park so
yeah I definitely need to up my mind
train coaster credit accounts but that's
something I'll work on in the future I
would love to write big Risley minecarts
actually definitely want to go to Hong
Kong one day if China is done trying to
take it over have I been to any Belgian
theme parks I've been to Bobby Allen's
and Varley B and I have to say Bobby on
land has a lot of nostalgic value to me
because I went there when I was younger
and Revolution was my favorite coaster I
suppose when I didn't dare to ride
coasters it was like it scared the hell
out of me when I was younger but it was
probably the actually most intense
coaster I wrote when I was younger and
then by the time I got over my fear of
roller coasters when I was like 19 I
think I wrote revolution again and I
still love it it's so good see how that
has a bunch of nostalgic value for me
but mmm it kind of sucks nowadays my
favourite would definitely be wannabe
psyche underground is amazing
I'm from the Netherlands but I'm living
in Brussels
um hope so yeah I'll come to your
question technique any tips on how to
start and design a dark ride oh that's
actually a really difficult question for
me I rarely make dark rides you might
have noticed that there are no dark
rides on my channel so I don't know too
much about how to do a dark ride really
but Trek first I think and try to keep
in mind what you want to do around the
track and then build up scenery around
it but you absolutely have to get the
trek in first because I think you need
to be able to tell from the POV what the
ride is going to look like as you build
it
don't say anything in favor of democracy
on this stream well Oh God now I already
got some weird conversations about this
on my Chinese planet Zoo video but I
mean obviously I'm Pro Hong Kong I mean
from a democratic country
it's just ridiculous what's going on
there but at the same time I don't think
it would deter me from going to Hong
Kong as far as I've heard from people
the situation for foreigners coming
there is still fine I just hope that the
Hong Kong is themselves are not losing
their democratic freedom what makes you
move to Belgium and how do you survive
the roads well what made me move was
just the specific study that I'm
interested in
also the tuition fees are lower I pay
about half the tuition fees I do here
for them as I do for the Netherlands
actually monetarily it's a bit of a gain
for me that I've moved to Belgium and
kind of making use of Belgium that's not
great actually but I also try to promote
it because I think Belgium is a much
nicer country than most Dutch people
give it credit for the roads are not
even that bad until you go into some
parts of Wallonia but yeah I really like
it here
have her plaintiff plopsaland I wanted
to go there recently but then my
roommate couldn't go and the plans never
actually ended up happening but I would
love to go there sometime soon
I tried actually recently to go back to
an old dark right that I was working on
planned in planet coaster I was actually
working on the dark ride but I lost a
lot of progress because some of the
pieces that I used to build it were tea
makers toolkit pieces and when I opened
the park the game told me that some
pieces were missing and apparently they
must have been taken from the workshop
or something because a bunch of floor
pieces just disappear and another hole
right looks really weird so I'm not
really motivated to finish that honestly
it is effectively Italy of the north
yeah it has a really good food I haven't
been to Boulevard actually oh yeah and
German roads are bad not all of them but
some parts of the Autobahn are really
really terrible yeah and at least
Vilonia doesn't have traffic jams but
then again I was recently recently some
some Flemish people in class were
showing like where they lived and y'all
Flemish people have gie into houses and
everybody's just kind of scattered
throughout the country there's so much
urban sprawl so that just kind of makes
the whole of flanders really congested
and kind of messy and ugly but at the
same time everybody has a beautiful
house so there's a bit of a trade-off
there it's right up that I think it's
not worth it
but you know that's the trade-off you
guys made I suppose have I tried
rimworld I've actually heard of it but I
haven't tried it I have to be honest I'm
really bad at starting new games I just
really tend to stick to a few games that
I do play
all right I wanted to end the stream a
while ago but just I don't know I want
to round it up they want to respond to
some of the last questions and comments
Flanders the whole Belgium well not to
be honest Flanders is a lot more urban
sprawl a than balunia you can definitely
already tell if you look on Google Maps
anyway I'm sorry but I'm really gonna
have to end the stream here this will be
it for Jaeger horn from me but of course
you can download it on the Steam
Workshop as well I'll put the link in
the description when the video of this
live stream goes live so if you want to
check out the coaster for yourself and
do some on rides with a better frame
rates than I can get then by all means
download it and check it out see if you
can run it and yeah that'll be it's for
Jaeger horn I really really enjoyed
building this thing it's definitely my
proudest build in planet coaster I think
but there there is a time to move on and
now especially with planets ooh around
the corner I'm sorry guys but I gotta
give that planet zoo thing it's right so
thanks for coming to the stream
everybody and thanks for watching and
hopefully I'll see you in the next
planet coaster video planet zoo video
parks tax video City skylines video
whatever it is hopefully I'll see you
next time I'm doing something creative
again hi guys